c'est une activité qui se pratique
partout dans le monde et aussi une
classique de spéléo arpenter des tunnels
de lave lampe frontale et cordes en main
une activité en plein boom à la réunion
descente immédiate dans les entrailles
du volcan du côté du tremblay dans la
coulée de 2004 récemment ouverte en
spéléo par aymeric moniteurs et brevet
d'état de spéléo on va rentrer par une
entrée basse pour passer sous la route
les sortir du cil de trois heures dans
la montagne tout la houle
on fera à peu près 1 km de traversée
elle a coulé moi je les découvertes par
le bouche à oreille puisque ya des gens
qui habitent sur place il ya les agents
de l'eau élèves qui gère un peu le parc
et puis ben le milieu du plein air il
est petit donc assez rapidement
il a été connu paye avéré tunnels de
lave dans le secteur qu'il était
intéressant le tunnel conduite en ce
moment un appartement où il n'ya pas de
verticalité yara de nage c'est pas une
rivière souterraine 1 donc on est dans
les cavités accessible de classe
le principal de la progression le la
difficulté principale réside dans le
fait de se balader sous terre des
courbes et à quatre pattes en camping et
surtout de faire attention à pas se
faire mal parce qu'on évolue dans un
milieu très très agressif ou la moindre
chute d'un ce qu'on se blesse assez
gravement à ses du basalte agressif et
on s'ouvre très très vite il ya une
petite sortie rascalou campagnari plus
large que l'autre
qu'est-ce qu'on atteindra hand
supposerait sans rancune étant donné que
le tunnel suit la pente
globalement on n'est jamais au delà de
trois mètres de profondeur sous la
surface en à peu près 3 mètres de
plafond donc disons que arrondissons au
maximum une dizaine de mètres sous terre
mais bon c on se sent enfermé qu'on soit
10 mètres sous terre où il met sous
terre l'ascension la sensation
globalement c'est la même ali si on est
donc un contre et seulement
contrairement aux compressions mans
karstique
donc c'est un refroidissement hyper
rapide c'est comme de la cire la cire
d'une bougie est ici donc on pourrait
apparenter ça une forme de grand prix on
retrouve évidemment dans le quartier
classé à un refroidissement extrêmement
lent et on revient ici denquin la forme
toutes ses formes c'est que ces endroits
qui sont bombées c'est le
refroidissement qui a permis de faire ça
le fait de rentrer et de sortir d'un
côté pour gérer un groupe dans le milieu
un peu oppressant comme celui là avec un
tunnel qui est quand même un peu de
poudre c'est noir c'est un gros avantage
de dire aux gens qu'on progresse
toujours vers la sortie qu'on n'aura pas
le chemin à refaire dans l'autre sens et
le fait les traversées ans paie l'eau
sont relativement rares donc ça c'est
intéressant
c'est devenu un produit touristique
puisque le l'accessibilité de la qualité
permet de faire une petite visite
accessible un petit peu des gens pas
forcément sportifs qui vont se balader
dans la première partie
la traversée elle par contre un peu plus
sportive
ça demande quand même un peu
d'adaptation des forts avec des moments
des petits problèmes respiratoires et
des tunnels faut avancer doucement parce
qu'on s'essouffle vite l'intérêt de ce
genre d'expédition au delà de communier
avec le volcan la spécificité de
nous avec un potentiel des visites de
tunnels de lave qui était en train de
s'en rendre compte et aussi important
car wade ccsa permettent à mener une
activité nouvelle et ça peut localement
créer une dynamique qui amène les gens à
faire de la spéléo ailleurs